herzlich kommt doch wieder heute ich
habe heute wieder ein video für uns
ausgesucht was wir uns definitiv
reinziehen müssen ist es ein video aus
der kategorie schockierend und ist ein
video ist der kategorie das ist so
tatsächlich mal im fernsehen gelaufen es
handelt sich dabei um eine folge von dem
format hot five für alle von euch den
hot five kein begriff ist das ist eine
sendung bei der entweder fünf frauen
oder fünf männer vor einer jury von
jeweils anderen geschlecht stehen also
männer werden von frau bewertet frauen
von männern und dann geht es nur darum
dass leute halbnackt darstellt und
fertig gemacht werden
56 sie blondine in kämpfen heute um den
titel der haut ruhig auf dem weg
okay okay leute wir haben fünf kunden
die um den titel der hot five queen
konkurrieren leute also wir merken wir
sind ja auch schon mal laut mal leise zu
einer ganz heißen sache hier unterwegs
okay da wird gleich richtig abgehen
wir werden heute die fähren die hot five
screen sehen das ist doch normal
also wenn das nicht zwei dinge vorneweg
hatte der toskana auf dem das video
erschienen ist in der beschreibung
bedingt da könnt ihr euch die ganze
folge auch selbst mal reinziehen und die
support und wie immer geht bei diesen
kanal dass ich die anwende relativ kurz
halten muss weil das sonst einfach mit
youtube probleme gibt also wenn ihr euch
manchmal denkt jeder das noch mal laufen
würde ich auch machen geht aber nicht so
dass ich die konsequenzen darum geht es
nämlich letzten endes also die tanzen
wie gesagt von der jury einfach rum aber
das ist einfach es ist geisteskrank
stumpf es ist wirklich geist karstadt
man fasst sich tatsächlich an den kopf
einerseits wieso leute mitmachen aber
das ist mal außen vor
aber auch wenn die dann da sind was da
wirklich passiert es ist krank und dann
ja kommen solche reaktionen bei raus wie
einfach bei dass leute heute im
fernsehen
in den kategorien gesicht dekolleté und
ort fit also mal ganz so ernst wissen
wie es mir denken wenn ich das hier sehe
ich denke mir wissen sie ist eigentlich
nicht besser
ja das ist mein geld hätte bin ich dafür
was ist meine meinung wissen es die
teilnehmer hier diese mädels hier
mitmachen nicht besser dass sie sich
nicht von vorneherein gedacht haben egal
wenn ich hier mitmache
ich schaue immer das skript durch auf
dem skript bekommen so dasteht nicht
mehr einfach anhand meiner hilfe zwar
stumm tippen und asch wert bewertet und
und gesicht auch noch wer macht er damit
dass ich so geil schauspieler alex aus
münchen hatten veranstalter gegen aus
bochum
[Musik]
also man muss auch dazu sagen die ganze
sendung ist ein bisschen älter also die
wurde schon vor schätzungsweise weiß
nicht zehn jahren war so aufgenommen
wenn nicht sogar mehr
der style der hier an den tag gelegt
wird heute gemerkt dass selbst ist ein
antiker auf jeden fall
es ist ein trip der aus dem einen oder
anderen historischen museum stammen
könnte
gerade diese justin bieber gedenkt
frisur
[Gelächter]
also ihr wisst ja leute bei mir auf
einem kanal kommt es öfter mal zweifel
an der menschheit auf hier zweifeln wir
gleich in mehrerer hinsicht der erste
grund ist eben dass dieses format
überhaupt existiert so dass es schon ein
bisschen stur meinetwegen aber dann dass
die leute da hingehen und wirklich
einfach nicht checken was sie da machen
ich kann das ich kann mir das wirklich
nicht so ernst anschauen ich kann mir
das auch nicht nur anschauen und lachen
ich fühle wirklich ein bisschen mit ihm
ist es falsch von mir das zu sagen
wollte ich fühle ein bisschen mit ihnen
dass sie überhaupt da mitgemacht haben
checkte was ich meine leute ich weiß ich
kann nicht ihre genauen bewegt und dann
muss man sagen ja genau motivation warum
sie das gemacht haben aber ich denke mir
dass die ihr wisst es doch
wahrscheinlich nicht besser oder also
ich sollte jetzt eigentlich besser
wissen dass das nicht so schlau ist das
nicht das okay der das finde ich ein
bisschen sympathischer als sympathischer
ist vielleicht der falsche begriff dafür
aber das finde ich ein bisschen doch da
kann ich mehr zu retten als zu leuten
die sagen dass sie da sind um zu
beweisen dass kleine frauen oder mütter
auch sexy sein können
was sollte was machen sie in dieser
sendung schaut es euch an ja ja ich
glaub ich gebe zu so ist es schon ein
bisschen älter ja ich weiß nicht genau
was da in dem moment in denen in manchen
köpfen vorgänger als die jetzt diese
sache passiert ist das ist dass das geht
überhaupt nicht diddy hat die hat doch
verstanden ist sabine 21 einer von den
wenigen personen die zu hat fünf gehen
und tatsächlich checken was passiert was
mit ihnen passiert fast sondern man muss
auch sagen auch sie krabbelt bei der
vorstellung auf allen vieren und macht
geräusche von der raubkatze kann man
natürlich jetzt auch sagen was
haben sie alle aber welches gesicht
kommt bei der jury
da muss ich ja sagen welches gesicht
kommt bei der jury am besten anleger da
steige ich noch direkt mal in die türe
ein
ich muss sagen wirklich ausgezeichnete
punktzahl gibt es für sie ist es nicht
sogar die die gescheckte was abgeht
sabine 21 ist mascha la la scha la
einfach
[Musik]
liga ist zuges zu bild leute dass diese
diese videos ich weiß dass leute ich
weiß nicht ob ihr nicht zu jung seien
dafür kennt ihr noch avril lavigne die
hier sieht aus wie avril lavigne digger
und der eine aus der jury sieht aus wie
justin bieber ist das ist eine
zeitkapsel diese sendung ist der
zeitkapsel in die vergangenheit nein es
muss auf die 1 du musst auf die einst
trust trust glaube es mir youtuber 24
aus köln okay ich habe einfach du gehst
auf die 1 wahrscheinlich haben sich
trotzdem nicht gemacht
egal
[Musik]
das ist so unangenehm es ist so
unangenehm dass sie vor allem auch dann
noch untereinander das vorhandene leute
schlimm genug wenn die einzelnen vor die
türe gehen und die jury dann so
stillschweigend für sich entscheidet
geht das jetzt platz eins hier die space
2 display stylings platz vier nach
müssen sie erst untereinander
ausdiskutieren auf höchstem level und zu
sagen so na ja also wir finden jetzt du
bist hässlich hat sich und dann nachdem
sie sich gegenseitig schon mal gemacht
haben kommt dann noch die jury und dann
geht noch das nächste level oben drauf
also es ist ein traum leute die sensible
sandra mit der meinung ihrer
konkurrenten konfrontiert ich zu
betreiben
es ist doch einfach wie im englischen
gibt es ein wort leute was ich manchmal
verwende für die sachen die wir hier auf
diesem kanal anschauen dieses wort ist
schätzt es ist einfach eine show was wir
hier sehen leute so nicht ich muss es
wirklich noch mal sagen was ich fühle
wirklich mit ihr weil ich glaube so wie
ich sie jetzt ja ein schutz ich habe
jetzt auch nur zwei minuten video von
ihr gesehen als ich kann ja nicht gut
einschätzen
aber ich könnte mir denken dass gerade
so junge mädels zu so einer sendung
geben weil ich denke so hey ich aber ins
fernsehen oder so und dann gibt es da
zack auf die fresse und dann denken sie
sich so scheiße
das tut jetzt bisschen weh das kann ich
mir vorstellen dass du schon seit ich
schaue die leute deswegen wegen quint
schauen wir dass wir den krieg genießen
leute und das ist die frage die ich mir
stelle ich das hier sehe die eta die
stehen doch direkt gegenüber erst wissen
die sich gegenseitig und müssen so
verhandeln so wer keine ahnung wer die
schönste schönste gesicht hat danach
wird die schönsten brüste hat whatever
alter und dann platzieren sie sich noch
mal alle geschlossenen vor jury und
kriegen dann nochmal eingedrückt das ist
doch es ist ein einziges fest
trotzdem leute müssen wir mal eine sache
ansprechen die ja auch die ganze mit dem
raum matches die ich so explizit glaube
ich noch nicht genannt haben haben
dieses fonds diese sache ist
geisteskrank oberflächlich falls ich
auch nicht gedacht habt jetzt mit sie
hierdurch unterschwellig gedacht aber
vielleicht nicht explizit im kopf die
sache ist wirklich so krank
oberflächlich es geht ja nur
ausschließlich jetzt hierbei um äußere
kriterien soll es ist ja nur die ursache
wie gesicht brüste und hintern stumpfer
kann es eigentlich nicht machen kann man
nicht zumindest was sowieso wie charisma
reinnehmen oder so dass man nicht ein
bisschen reden lässt aber ich meine es
gibt auch mit männern wo männer von
frauen geredet wenn das man die einfach
ein bisschen reden lässt so und einfach
ein bisschen die personen wirken lässt
und nicht nur einfach so
so leid es uns eigentlich auch tut aber
gewöhnen eigentlich das leben trotzdem
business sandra was geht ab herzlich
willkommen zu diesem firma wir freuen
uns dass du mitgemacht hast bei hot five
wir wollen dir an dieser stelle mal
ausdrücklich bescheinigen mit dieser
fünf die wir jetzt hier die hand drücken
dass du wirklich die hässlichste bisher
der runde
so und jetzt sage was dazu in die kamera
leute ich sag jetzt mal ein smalltalk
jetzt mal keinen chip von mir glaub mir
mal ich habe auch schon ein bisschen
kann jemals sehen werde ich ein paar
sachen gemacht so ich habe auch schon
mal online dating gemacht und man kann
einfach an so was wie rein äußerlichen
kriterien wie fotos oder what er war
nichts festmache kasten ist von mir
zumindest ja also wie oft habe ich da
schon in welche mails gesehen die ich
dann durch die frau rechts ist aber ich
meine chance und dann habe ich mal ein
paar von denen getroffen dicker und das
ist so oft nach hinten los gegangen
glaubt mir weil einfach so rein
äußerlichkeiten fotos j er war sagt mich
zu einer person aus ihr habt jetzt zwei
optionen leute entweder er selbst geht
zu hot five und werdet von drei etwas
fragwürdigen typen gibt ist oder jetzt
vorgeschlagene trier ab und abonniert
loben einen kanal
ich bin an der stadt daraus hat rein